è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fatti j
oggi siamo tornati su the forest arriva
il ragazzo è successo che hanno aggiunto
un casino di cose la l'ultima volta tipo
questa roba che cosa che altro di
rappresentativamente è un panel
cellulare che non ha linee ovviamente
però la punta i passi utile cazzo hanno
agito proprio un casino di cose nuove
quindi volevo vedere se riuscivo a fare
qualcosa di diverso
spero ci sia qualcosa di differente dal
ed alle palle da tennis almeno stavolta
è una cosa meravigliosa una torcia
grazie a dio cabello come sai dove va
non fate la reincarnazione di houdini
fatta iguana praticamente sparisce a
cazzo devi morire perché invisibile
annuncio fame allora ragazzi è
diversissimo costi cielo giù perché
cazzo c'è un naso quest'albero
due minuti di gioco troppo nasi agli
alberi fantastico questo è già tagliato
cazzola tagliato questo ovviamente
ragazzi la casa nola che hanno aggiunto
che hanno messo un non questo non questo
come cazzo si apre il menù non mi
ricordo più
ok perfetto che prima c'era una zattera
normale che che non funziona adesso
raggiunto la casa zattera porca [ __ ]
che figo quindi ragazzi cercano di
costruire sta a casa nel corso degli
episodi almeno un sacco di scappare una
volta per tutte ci fa pil albero di
avatar se ci fa salgono non è che
affermi che cos'è sta roba
fanta bello che non so come ci sono
entrato ma giuro che non riesco più c'è
un coniglio fermi due conigli morite uno
l'ho preso dove l'altro lo prenderò mai
ragazzi ho perso il coniglio ma non
importa meno male che ho trovato la
spiaggia almeno quell'ora che ha
terminato mondo velava salve sentare per
caso sa dove la barca perché c'ha dei
cibi
cos'è questa roba
io non capisco cosa sta roba ma non
capisco perché ci sono approvati sulla
spiaggia salve senta io io vengo sono fa
vj vengo in pace enormità per cioè cazzo
stai soffrendo un tuo compagno ma stai
amoreggiando con lui mi stai mangiando
la faccia una delle due cose non ho
capito
senta io io se vogliono delle barrette
di cioccolato qui ho anche un buon
coniglio se ha voglia perché già decisi
sulla caviglia posso unirmi al banchetto
se c'è una forchetta per favore che noi
posso mangiare così è scortese
sì però non ti incazzare punti in casa
questo fermo e cosa vuoi la io volevo
soltanto chiesto se potevo mangiare poi
anche dire di no hi tech e maleducato
del calcio proprio c'è gente che non che
non ha idea di che cosa sia l'ospitalità
proprio ma bravo bravo scappa scappa un
cazzo muore lo stand culo l'ho preso più
in pieno la brava brava fuori dai
[ __ ] fuori ma erotico giorno ariston
insomma ti mangio io adesso ragazze
ragazzi qualcuno vuole favorire un po di
manzotin mai mangiamo tutti prima o per
special hai per caso un contorno un po
di spinaci ragazzi quello quello che so
sulle braccia e ketchup e per con dirlo
meglio non fatevi strane idee io dovrei
mangiare quindi taglio per sei perfetto
e perché cazzo ho fatto un modo
virtualmente tagliandoli la faccia
ragazzi se qualcuno vuole favorire o
braccia e gambe per tutti ha detto c'è
un ampio
ancora capito sta ancora da dove minchia
salta fuori non si sa se facciamo st
barca prima che il nostro prima che
arrivino gli altri ok allora dove la
metto come si mette sarò ma non fa
neanche mettere potreste evitare di fare
cose sconce grazie a questa mela
metterla l'altra no non lo è riposto la
mia fiducia in quella cazzo di barca e
non funziona meraviglioso rega vivi
scoccio se vado a controllare cosa c'è
qua dentro perché l'ultima volta ci sono
entrato e uscito
so che c'è gente brutta lo so ma ma
tutto ti puoi allagata ci posso andare
sotto come se non fosse allargata sa
cosa ancora non l'ho capita allora
fatevi prendere la torcia nato nino
perfetto minchia che si vede
decentemente la prima volta che vedo
recentemente in una caverna così fatemi
fare prima del molato perché se ciò che
finisce male allora mettiamo ok ok io
avanzai bari mente sono entrato qui
dentro c'è un motivo non è che sono
pazzo salvero trovare fottutamente una
pistola so che qua dentro da qualche
parte però ci sono sti stronzi magari si
spengo la luce non mi vedono come si
spegne la luce a [ __ ] anche perfetto
piano piano piano piano ho visto la mano
visto che non l'ho visto mi chiamo
cicala non ci credo non hanno visto che
casa fanno stanno stanno dormendo amico
ma un cazzo di letto poi parte lo è non
è che amico mio marito birillo che fa
scintille cosa forse c'è una torcia non
lo sò io nel dubbio vado via per una
cazzo di torcia prima che si sveglino be
lo picchia mi son preso malissimo ma è
normale che se mi giro si muovono 123 te
la do visto importate non malgré disco
non ho ancora visto sinceramente credo
sia un bug
spero sia un vago perché sono solo nella
merda ma salve bella signora va anche
bene scarpe che tentavo ad uscire con me
io e questi beni indigeni siamo amici
quindi se vuole c'è qualcosa qua dietro
i non so cosa la stanno proteggendo wind
io vado a rompere qualsiasi cosa sia e
nel suo bisogno di una pistola per
cortesia te la cavi
un giorno per caso dove è una pistola
per caso questi mi hanno visto ragazzi
merda non
[ __ ] no no allora vuoi fuori dove la
morto che dovranno critica [ __ ]
siete stranzi però potevano far finta di
rincorrermi come gli altri nvece no
bastardi proprio
se ne sono accorti pensavano che io
dormissi così ma io non sono abituato
così anche la torcia mi chiama lasciato
a torcere cosa ci fa una poltrona qua
sotto qualsiasi cosa compagna davanti ai
miei occhi ho io ho un braccio e non ho
paura di usarlo sono ricche dove sono
fin dove mai portato merda ma una
valigia fantastico non ne faccio una
valigia voglio solo uscire e ragazze una
cosa strana calma ma ai due tette amico
mio mi ha visto che mi ha visto ma non
riesce a prendermi perché sono troppo in
alto soca guardami bene quando ibra ma
quanto sei bella lega non ho capito se è
un maschio femmina cosa cazzo e sto coso
non lo so ha deciso che torno indietro
ragazzi con l'energia di nuovo al
massimo di scendere allo zero in qualche
secondo di sicuro quello su alcune in
fiamme come hai fatto a farti andare
alcune in fiamme fammi capire spera che
non mi veda perché troppo occupato a
spegnere il fuoco sulle chiappe però non
ne dubito salve merda
vorrei che mi ha visto mi ha visto di
morire ok cos'è promuovi il culo abuso
dove sto andando le capaci qualcosa è
addio regalo
no no no non ti spegnere mio dio almeno
non adesso allora carminati sì sì sì non
ci credo perché non ci posso credere via
di qui subito perché sono uscito non
fate domande non so come ho fatto mio
zio che porta di culo perché non so come
ho fatto uscire il nome lo chiedete non
ne ho idea
ecco cazzo mi stanno seguendo [ __ ]
uscito adesso non mi rompete il cazzo
ora non ci semi incorrono adesso mi
ammazzano mica sono uscito ora adesso
non mi tartassati maroni fuori dai o no
via borsa via stronza posavina se mi
toccano tutto sono morte possa
incazzarmi devo andare in mare guy inbar
dov'era la barca di una volta quella
lista va al sicuro almeno mi fermo qui
rega non posso proseguire a volte perché
non c'è più fame per proseguire
fantastico l'ansia l'ansia giuro
all'edizione posso mettere quanto e
foglie ciò fantastico almeno il fuoco
l'ha fatto subito visto che rendo grosso
lavoro che cosa mi ritrovi di nuovo
prima o poi andrebbe aver cucinato
perfetto o dio santo ti ringrazio ho
fatto 2.500 bassi fantastico ragazzi
secondo cazzo me ne può fregare se prima
vedevo non vedo più un cazzo adesso
fantastico secco i ragazzi vede una luce
gesù a 6 tuo caso sta roba quale che non
capisco
a noi l'anno e la zattera che avevo
fatto all'inizio mi chiama barca una
volta non era lì era dall'altra parte
non so come ha fatto a spostarsi se
riesco a sopravvivere la notte voglio
vedere cosa c'è sulla barca perché si è
spostata e non è possibile
facciamo colazione come si deve con un
bel coniglio anzi con una lucertola
enorme per chi è che non fa colazione
con una bella tazza di latte cereali e
lucertole fantastico una lucertola cruda
proprio l'acquolina in bocca giura cazzo
mi sono fatta a bruciarmi merda ok per
meno male chiaro che ci senti ho scritto
al mi dispiace ma devo ammazzarti ok
ucciso un piccione una cosa cazzo non un
nome l'ho visto l'ho visto ragazzino non
ma l'ho visto e mi sembra il momento
migliore per andare a vedere che cosa
c'è sulla barca prima di tutto sta roba
era era dall'altra parte non so come sia
arrivata fin qui c'è di sicuro qualcuno
e manovra perché non è possibile o hanno
imparato a guidare quel cazzo di cose di
mangiare così si ragazzi ha visto pari
con nova st avuto ho trovato ha avuto
una botta di culo allucinante peraltro
ho trovato la pistola sono immortale
adesso prova ad avvicinarsi prova ci
scusi uso questo che mi sembra più
economico per ora poi magari se se vedo
che sono aggressivi passo all'altro
questa sopra passo sopra da bravo da
bravo da bravo bravissimo ragazzi stanno
sono dei deficienti ma vabbè questo
anche sono un po deficiente no suo caso
non mi ha preso fantastico grado dove
scapito praga fermo cazzo dove vai dove
vai e vieni qui no no no tu non scapperà
che merda c'ero quasi è tornata indietro
se si fanno il bengala in torno indietro
il sen si vede che gli piace che ti
piace questo guarda si si usa così
prendi in mano e poi si clicca sinistro
ti piace mi sa che gli piace lega lo
vedo che è che contento perfetto si sta
pugnalando da solo se uno va a fuoco
ovviamente la cosa che cerca di fare
questa mi sembra la cosa giusta meno
male che i miei amici mi sono d'aiuto in
questa grandissima avventura perché se
non ci foste voi mi spiegate perchè ho
fatto un salto di un chilometro no
veramente è che ci siamo già che ci
siamo
dai che ci siamo se i ragazzi ce lo fa
ho rifatto la zattera parma
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai benissimo
ragazzi è stato fantastico mi mi
dispiace abbandonare la vecchia barca
perché è stata di grande aiuto
però se magari ci sto sopra ma io ci sto
correndo non voglio farla finire
un'altra volta ragazzi no non posso
girare non posso io vado a largo vado a
largo così che bella zattera fantasmi
giuro che è sicurissima ci si può
fermare un attimo no no no no no no no
no no no no con un'altra volta noi come
l'altra volta no
ragazzi io gli ho sorpassato in una
maniera fantastica e non mi hanno preso
non so come l'ultima volta ci sono
finito malissimo stavolta no [ __ ]
tutto maledizione sono so che mi sono
salvato per miracolo regala un aspetto
la notte poi prova ad andare a largo a
vedere che succede perché sono
impossibili dopo le comunque nel
prossimo episodio ragazzi per ora
concludo sperando di non fare la stessa
fine dell'altra volta i ragazzi servito
è piaciuto come al solito lasciato
commento mi piace anche alla pagina di
facebook e con ogni video tratte nella
descrizione sensi favore stilisti 20
anni ci vediamo al prossimo video delle
ragazze